H
KATIE PAVLICH, JESSE WATTERS,
AND GREG GUTFELD, 5:00 IN
NEW YORK CITY, THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
DEMOCRATS CAUGHT BREAKING COVID
RULES AT THE FIGHT OVER VACCINE
MANDATES REACHES A CRITICAL
POINT, PRESIDENT BIDEN DEFINED A
CITY WIDE MANDATE IN D.C. AFTER
HE AND THE FIRST LADY WERE
SPOTTED MASKLESS AT A RITZY
RESTAURANT WHILE SECRET SERVICE
MEMBERS WERE COVERED UP,
EXCUSING THE BEHAVIOR THIS WAY.
>> THERE IS A MASK REQUIREMENT
INSIDE D.C. RESTAURANTS, YET
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE
FIRST LADY WERE NOT WEARING
MASKS WHILE WALKING AROUND A
D.C. RESTAURANT ON SATURDAY,
WHY?
>> I THINK WHAT WE ARE REFERRING
TO IS A PHOTO OF THEM WALKING
OUT OF A RESTAURANT AFTER THEY
HAD EATEN, MASTS IN HAND WHERE
THEY ARE NOT YET PUT THEM BACK
ON IT, SO I WOULD SAY, OF COURSE
THERE ARE MOMENTS WHEN WE ALL
DON'T PUT MASKS BACK ON AS
QUICKLY AS WE SHOULD, BUT I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD LOSE THE
FOREST THROUGH THE TREES HERE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN NOT
ALONE, CHECK OUT MAYOR LIGHTFOOT
AFTER BEING MASK LIST AT A GAME,
OVER HALF OF THE CITY'S 13,000
OFFICERS COULD BE FIRED IF THEY
DON'T GET THE SHOT.
TODAY IS ALSO THE DEADLINE FOR
SEATTLE'S POLICE OFFICERS TO
ADMIT THEIR VACCINATION STATUS,
HERE IS THE ONE RIGHT AWAY FROM
A WASHINGTON TROOPER FINDING OUT
FOR THE LAST TIME.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CITIZENS OF YEAH, COUNTY AS WELL
AS MY FELLOW OFFICERS UP IN THE
VALLEY, WITHOUT YOU GUYS I WOULD
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL, AND KEPT
ME SAFE AND GOING WITH MY FAMILY
EVERY NIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I WISH I COULD SAY MORE, BUT
THIS IS IT.
SO THIS IS THE LAST TIME YOU
WILL HEAR ME IN A STATE PATROL
CAR.
AND THEY CAN KISS MY [BLEEP].
>> Dana: SO HE IS OUT OF THE
BUILDING.
>> Jesse: DID ANY OF THESE
POLITICIANS THINK ABOUT
ATTRITION, THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN WHEN YOU SLAP THESE
MASKS MANDATES ON PEOPLE.
RIGHT NOW IN SEATTLE THEY WILL
LOSE 140 OFFICERS IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CRIME WAVE, HISTORIC.
WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN RETIREMENTS
THEY ARE, AND THEY ARE GOING
INTO WHAT THEY CALL PHASE FOR
MOBILIZATION, DANA, AND ONLY USE
THIS DURING RIOTS, IT'S WHEN
EVERY SINGLE SWORN OFFICER HAS
TO COME IN SEVEN DAYS A WEEK,
12-HOUR SHIFTS AND COVER EACH
OTHER'S --
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW THEY WILL
DO THAT AFTER THEY HAVE HAD JUST
SHATTERED A THREE DECADE
MURDERER NUMBER LAST YEAR,
ALREADY ON PACE TO TOP THAT END
IN KINGS COUNTY 80% OF THE
DRIVE-BYS ARE BLACK AMERICANS,
SO JENNY DURKAN THE MAYOR, BLACK
LIVES MATTER, DON'T THEY?
YOU WANT TO KEEP POLICE OFF THE
STREETS AND THAT TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT?
I COULD TALK ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
DINNER, DANA, HUNTER BIDEN MUST
HAVE PICKED UP THE TAB ON THIS
THING, BECAUSE THE RESTAURANT IS
EVEN TOO PRICEY FOR GUTFELD.
THEY HAVE A CAVIAR TASTING FOR
$250, THEN THEY HAVE SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER EVEN HEARD BEFORE,
AND THE NEW ZEALAND SCORPION
FISH FOR $275, EIGHT DOVER SOLD
FOR 115, I'VE NEVER SEEN IT OVER
110.
AND THEN THE GUY MUST'VE HAD A
LOT OF COCKTAILS LAST NIGHT,
BECAUSE HE DID NOT EVEN SHOW UP
TO WORK TODAY, JOE BIDEN HAS NO
PUBLIC EVENTS ON HIS SCHEDULE
TODAY.
I HOPE IT WAS WORTH IT.
THIS IS WHY THIS GUY IS SO
DISCOMBOBULATED.
HE WALKS INDOORS THREE D.C.
RESTAURANT WITH NO MASK, BUT
DOES A ZOOM CALL BY HIMSELF WITH
A FULL MASK ON.
THAT'S WHY THIS COUNTRY IS SO
CONFUSED ABOUT COVID, HE IS
CONFUSED.
AND THEN IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WHY DO THEY EVEN HAVE THE MASK
MANDATE?
SEVEN-DAY DEATH AVERAGE IN D.C.
IS 0.
IT IS 0.
WHY DON'T THEY PUT ON A BULLET
PROOF VEST MANDATE?
MORE PEOPLE DYING FROM BULLETS
AND COVID-19.
>> I WILL SAY WE HAVE DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF GETTING A
GOOD MAJORITY OF THE CITY
VACCINATED, SO BRAVO TO HIM
AERIAL VALOR FOR THAT AND I GET
IT, I THINK THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS THAT THESE MASK
MANDATES ARE ANNOYING AND
SOMETIMES MISLEADING BECAUSE ONE
CITY HAS THEM AND THE
NEIGHBORING CITY DOES NOT HAVE
THEM, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE ELECTED
LEADERS WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO LEAD
THE PEOPLE NOT WEARING A MASK,
IT'S REALLY HARD TO THEN TELL
JOHN Q. PUBLIC, AND TO HAVE YOUR
MASK ON --
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT
LORI LIGHTFOOT ON THAT?
>> Richard: HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT AS SHE
LOOKS AT THE CHICAGO PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND HOW SHE IS NOT
TESTING THE STUDENTS THEY ARE,
BUT IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THAT
WHAT IS HAPPENING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT LIKE ALL THE OTHER
CITY EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO TAKE THE VACCINE, RIGHT?
THE EDUCATORS OF CHICAGO, 90% OF
THEM ARE VACCINATED.
AND THEY TURN IN THEIR VACCINE
CARDS NO PROBLEM, CITY
EMPLOYEES, THE SAME.
SHE HAS ALSO ALLOWED THAT IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO GET THE VACCINE,
IF YOU DO NOT WANT TO TURN IN
THE VACCINE CARD, YOU CAN TEST
TWICE A WEEK, SO IF YOU TEST
TWICE A WEEK YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TURN IN THE VACCINATION CARD.
WHAT I CAN'T FATHOM IS THIS,
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE KEEP POLICE OFFICERS SAFE AND
WORKING.
AND WE KNOW AN OFFICER REPORTED
THAT THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
DEATH FOR POLICE OFFICERS IN
2021 AND 2020 HAS BEEN COVID-19,
WHY WOULD YOU NOT WANT TO KEEP
YOUR POLICE OFFICER SAFE WHICH
IS THE BATTLE THAT SHE SEEMS TO
BE HAVING.
>> Dana: KATIE, LISTEN TO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT THIS IS
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT POLICE
INSURRECTION.
>> POLICE UNIONS ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO STRIKE, IT IS IN
THEIR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT AND IN STATE LAW, WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN FROM THE LEADERSHIP
IS A LOT OF MISINFORMATION, A
LOT OF FACTORIES AND FRANKLY
FLAT OUT LIES IN ORDER TO INDUCE
AN INSURRECTION.
>> Dana: I IMAGINE SOME OF THE
OFFICERS THAT DON'T WANT TO GET
VACCINATED ARE FRUSTRATED THAT
SHE GOES TO THE BASKETBALL GAME
AND DOES NOT HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK.
>> Katie: SHE GETS TO LIVE HER
LIFE WITH ARMED SECURITY WHILE
SHE TRIED TO DEFUND THE POLICE
LAST YEAR IT GETS TO DO THAT AND
LECTURING AND TELLING POLICE
OFFICERS THAT THEY ARE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS TRYING TO CREATE AN
INSURRECTION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
AND HAVE A UNION THAT IS
STANDING UP FOR THE RIGHT OF
CHOICE ABOUT WHETHER THEY WANT
TO BE VACCINATED OR NOT FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
NATURAL IMMUNITY, THEY HAVE SOME
OTHER KITCHEN -- CONDITION,
MAYBE THEY JUST DON'T WANT IT,
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT POLITICIANS
IN GENERAL HAVE HANDLED THIS AND
JOE BIDEN IN PARTICULAR, IT CAN
SEEM LIKE WELL, IT'S JUST A MASK
THAT HE DID NOT HAVE WHEN HE
WALKED OUT, BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE VIDEOS OF TODDLERS ON
AIRPLANES GETTING KICKED OFF
WITH HER PARENTS AND SCREAMING,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT KIDS SITTING AT
SCHOOL ALL DAY WHO ARE A LITTLE
WHO HAVE TO WEAR THAT FOR EIGHT
HOURS, IT IS INFURIATING TO
WATCH THE PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES DO THIS AND THEN
THE PROSPECT SAYING, WELL, WE
DON'T REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
THAT.
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS
IN D.C. AND THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINES IF YOU DON'T COMPLY, IF
YOU ARE ON AMTRAK AND YOU DON'T
HAVE YOUR MASK ON, THEY CAN KICK
YOU OFF THE TRAIN.
THEY CAN LAUGH ABOUT IT AND I
WOULD ARGUE NOBODY SHOULD BE
WEARING MASKS GIVEN THE
VACCINATION RATE AND THE NATURAL
IMMUNITY, BUT IF YOU FORCE
OTHERS AND THROW KIDS OFF WITH
THEIR PARENTS THAT ARE TRYING TO
SEE THEIR FAMILIES, THEN TAKE IT
AWAY FROM EVERYONE IF THAT IS
THE CASE.
>> Dana: FOR A BRIEF MOMENT I
THOUGHT, MAYBE WITH THE
HYPOCRISY ON THE MAP, MAYBE THEY
WILL JUST DECIDE WE CAN LET IT
GO AND LET IT BE PEOPLE'S CHOICE
IF THEY WANT TO WEAR A MASK OR
NOT, BUT APPARENTLY THAT IS NOT
HAPPENING.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE
THE POWER FROM THE POWERLESS AND
NO MASK DOES THAT WONDERFULLY.
AND WHY SHOULD LORI LIGHTFOOT
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK AND HIDE
THAT BEAUTIFUL SMILE?
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, SHE HAS SO
MUCH TO SMILE ABOUT.
TO HIDE IT IN MY OPINION IS A
CRIME.
WHEN YOUR TONGUE MET THE KIDS IN
EVERY THING LIKE THAT, WE ARE
NOW IN THE TYRANNY OF SAFETY
PHASE WHERE I HAD TO GO GET A
MEDICAL PROCEDURE ON FRIDAY, AND
ENDOSCOPY, IT WAS REQUIRED THAT
THE PERSON DRIVING ME THERE AND
THE PERSON PICKING ME UP HAD TO
BE EITHER MANDATED A SHOT OR
NEGATIVE COVID, EVEN IF THEY DID
NOT ENTER THE BUILDING.
THAT'S INSANE.
BUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
PRACTICAL BENEFITS OF MASKING,
IT'S ABOUT HOW THE JACK ASSES
THAT RELISH REPRIMANDING US DO
NOT FOLLOW THEIR OWN PROTOCOLS,
THAT'S WHY THEY GOT INTO
POLITICS SO THAT THEY COULD
CREATE THE CALLS THEY DON'T WANT
TO LIVE BY.
PEOPLE WHO SCOFF AT THE LIVES
THAT WE FOLLOW, WHEN THE LINE
CUTTERS ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
CONTROL THE LINE, THAT'S WAR.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE LET THEM EAT
CAKE PHASE OF THIS WHEN
SUMMONING IS TELLING YOU THE
RULES AND VIOLATING THEM IN
FRONT OF YOU ON THE SMALLER
SCALE IS LIKE POLITICAL
POLITICIANS WHO START WARS, BUT
TO THEIR KIDS ARE IMMUNE FROM
THE DRAFT, IT'S LIKELY CREATE
AND ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT WE ARE
THEN MOCKING AND SEE THIS AND
IT'S FROM TED KENNEDY TO HUNTER
BIDEN WITH HIS GUNS IN HIS
CRACK, POLITICAL POWER IS THAT
SAFETY NET THAT KEEPS YOU FROM
BEING ARRESTED OR BEING IN
TROUBLE, ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A
DEMOCRAT.
>> Jesse: HOW WAS YOUR
PROCEDURE?
>> Greg: IT WENT SMOOTH.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT.
>> Richard: WANT THAT TO GO
WELL.
>> Greg: THEY PUT THE CAMERA
DOWN THERE, THEY DID FIN